hi i'm seth rogan and this is the wired
auto complete interview
part two
i'm generally horrified to google myself
but uh i'm curious to see what's what's
flying around out there these days
all right who
is seth rogen valid question who is this
guy if you've googled this the answer is
me i am seth rogen who does seth rogen
look like if you're the average person
uh on the streets any other famous
jewish person who does seth rogen
playing the lion king i play uh pumbaa
the warthog in the new lion king who
does seth rogen's voice do people ask
that
as though i have another person doing
this the answer is me seth rogen i do
seth brogan's voice could you imagine
the infrastructure required to have
another human doing my voice that would
be insane if you have ever googled who
does seth rogen's voice you're an idiot
thank you so much
does seth rogen have a podcast yes seth
rogen does have a podcast it's called
story time with seth rogen it's one of
the most acclaimed things i've ever done
which uh is not saying much but people
do seem to enjoy it
did seth rogen invent the cross joint i
didn't i would say i probably played a
role in popularizing the cross joint but
we had like a book of like novelty
joints that someone had given us and we
rolled them in high school they were
like party it was like a party trick
kind of so no i
i only wish i had the ingenuity to
invent the cross joint i'm not an
engineer does seth rogen sell his
pottery i've never sold my own original
pottery i've sold replicas versions
things based on my pottery things i've
worked a long time designing and making
sure that they're good but not my actual
physical pottery that i've made seth
rogen celebrate christmas no
seth rogen is jewish does seth rogen
play call of duty i used to probably up
until like five years ago when i was
playing one of the newer calls of duty
calls of duty call of duties and i just
couldn't do it and i was like this is
the moment that i am too old to play
these games and i put call of duty away
and i've not played it since
okay how seth rogen how did seth rogen
get his start i started doing stand-up
comedy in vancouver british columbia
when i was around 13 years old that led
me to getting an agent and then i found
myself on the television show freaks and
geeks and i essentially work with a lot
of the same people uh i did since then
how did seth rogen meet jay bearshell on
the show undeclared i met him at the
audition and then probably the screen
test was the first time i hung out with
him and we brought him in and i remember
him uh explaining to me that his
favorite movie was fight club and if he
got the show he was gonna buy a ferrari
i think he was greatly underestimating
the amount of taxes we would be paying
in relation to our salaries at that time
how old was seth rogan in donnie darko
18 maybe i think i was probably eight my
parents were not on the set so i was
probably 18 years old it was my first
film role yeah and i worked with uh jake
gyllenhaal who it was one of his first
films and i remember thinking this guy
is going to be much more successful than
me and i was right
how to pickle like seth rogen by that
you mean pickle a human
i hope that's not what people mean if
the answer is that i think you can't i
think if you're wondering can you pickle
yourself like i did in the movie an
american pickle you cannot do that thank
you
is seth rogen alive last i checked but
it's been debated if i die between now
and when this airs it would be spooky is
seth rogen banned from north korea i
assume
i think everyone's kind of banned from
north korea it's not an easy place to
just go to
is seth rogen friends with adele no this
might be referring to the fact that i
was sitting front row at her television
special i've never met adele and that's
the closest i've ever been to adele i'm
a big fan and if you're not you're a
because adele's
objectively good i'm not saying you
gotta play adele like
all the time but if you don't
like adele
period you're not a good person it's
seth rogen god the movie ghostbusters
has taught me to say yes to this
question is sith rogan's laugh real from
the people that brought you the question
who does seth rogen's voice comes to
step could you imagine the
life i would be leading to have had to
maintain a manufactured laugh
since
the late 90s that's like these actors
who who are bald who pretend they're not
bald i look at them and i'm like the
life you've chosen to lead what have you
done here just be bald there's bald
people ed harris sexy man
bald there's hundreds of bald men that
are sexy are you kidding me larry
david's a good looking ball that bruce
willis great look about jason state the
entire cast of fast and furious bald
ball ball ball bald all baldos it's why
they're so fast
and furious you can transcend baldness
is what i'm saying with others
attributes what seth rogen what is seth
rogan like in real life i wish i knew at
this point honestly
i think kind of like this this is not a
thing i do in like my normal life so not
specifically like this but i'd say in
general i get i don't have someone else
doing my voice or my laugh or something
like that
what camp did seth rogen go to i went to
a camp called camp miriam some of my
best friends to this day i met at camp
miriam or mahan miriam as we called it
because it was a jewish camp my sister
and her friends rent it out from time to
time and i went there maybe four or five
years ago and it was weird it was
exactly the same they have not like
changed anything there was a graffiti i
had written that was still like on the
walls of the cabin
what show
did seth rogen write on i've written on
a few tv shows the first one was
undeclared which was on fox we premiered
uh i believe september 17 2001 not the
best release date for a light comedy
show and the show did not do well and
was cancelled pretty quickly after i
think uh 16 episodes maybe but i was a
writer on that and then i was a writer
on the alley g show in 2004
i think
what color is seth rogan's hair
i assume there's not a word missing
there right my hair is uh
i don't know brownish gray with more and
more skin color poking through
but i've decided to bald to not be like
these other men you will watch me bald i
will be on that list one day i did turn
to my wife the other day and i said one
day you will be married to a bold man
just so you know it might not be for a
while it might be decades from now but i
will bolt and i will not hide it it's
already happening i'm sure if you're a
huge fan of mine you've noticed it over
the years
thank you so much who seth rogen who did
seth rogen write super bad with i wrote
it with my friend evan goldberg who i
still work with to this day we met at uh
in bar mitzvah class when we were 12
years old and we went to high school
together we wrote pineapple express
together we direct uh this is the end
together in the interview and we uh
produced together and he's still uh one
of my very best friends and we still
write together we started writing superb
we were like 13 years old basically when
we started high school it's like
embarrassing how similar it is to the
finished movie that we made that is
still what many consider one of the best
things i've ever had anything to do with
i've had to grapple a lot with the fact
that i did a lot of that when i was like
15 years old so yeah
who does seth rogen play in invincible i
play alan the alien in invincible and
it's a wonderful show i recommend you
watch it it's like
there is dramatic elements to the role
and there's comedic elements to the role
i was glad people accepted me as alan
the union because he's a very muscular
figure and whenever i'm accepted as a
muscular person even in the context of
an animated superhero show it's
it's flattering who is seth rogen's
agent
united talent agency is my agent i don't
know if they don't want their name set
that's enough that's all you need to
know who plays seth rogen's dad and
knocked up the late great harold ramis
plays my dad and knocked up he's in
ghostbusters he plays egon spangler he
directed uh groundhog day which was one
of the greatest comedies of all time and
uh he has written countless other
amazing comedies and directed other
countless amazing comedies and i met him
at the doville film festival with judd
apatow when we were there in 2000 we
were there with four-year-old virgin we
asked him if he would play my father uh
and he said yes and it was fantastic
is seth rogen is seth rogen vegan seth
rogen is not vegan i eat vegan things at
times sometimes i'll
find myself having eaten something vegan
and i'll think oh
not bad sometimes i'll think look at you
you're really doing it is seth rogan
making a new movie yeah i have made a
movie that'll come out around
thanksgiving called the fableman's uh
directed by steven spielberg and i also
this year we'll be making another new
movie there are more seth rogen movies
coming your way i don't usually talk
about myself in the third person please
include that
is seth rogen friends with eminem i
wouldn't say i'm friends with eminem if
i saw him at him i would go talk to him
and i'd be happy to see him and i assume
he'd be happy to see me so i would say
i'm a friendly acquaintance with eminem
but i
you know if i'm like making a list of
like people to invite over for a
barbecue eminem is not on it nor has he
ever invited me to anything so i think
he feels similarly is seth rogen the
yellow eminem no
i'm not an eminem and i wouldn't be in
eminem you know what
i would never be an eminem
what seth rogen directed
i like how they worded that seth rogen
directed this is the end and the
interview and uh the pilot for the show
preacher as well as some episodes of
that and the pilot for the show black
monday as well as some episodes of that
that's most of it what is seth rogen
zodiac sign uh
i was born april 15th aries i'm an aries
what is seth rogen's phone number
watch the eric andre show
you will find it what does seth rogen
drive for a long time i had a toyota
highlander and i really liked it and
then i was like i can afford a range
rover and then i got one of those and i
like it much more
that was the wired auto complete
interview thank you for searching and
thank you for watching
[Music]